hey I'm about to kill everybody
disturbing video shows a Florida man's
shocking Outburst in the back of a squad
car after he's arrested for allegedly
attempting to abduct children outside of
an elementary school
on August 25th multiple 9-1-1 calls came
into dispatch in Brooksville Florida a
town about one hour north of Tampa
callers reported a man acting bizarre
near Eastside Elementary School
address emergency
there's a Man Out by a school
screaming his name is Christopher
Lucifer but he's going to light up his
electric fence and kill people
and what school is he mine
Eastside Elementary
um I'm right here by Eastside Elementary
School
what's happening
you've got two guys over here screaming
about how they're going to spray people
up
making gun Jesters cussing and screaming
to the point that people are not walking
with their children one caller told
dispatch she was worried about students
who were walking home from school
there's kids walking home from school
and
I don't think it's really safe for them
to be walking with two people arguing
and Ill with each other like that yeah
officials say the suspect identified as
36 year old Christopher Pavlik grabbed
two students ages seven and nine outside
of the school they alleged Pavlik took
hold of their backpacks to stop the kids
from getting away when Hernando County
sheriff's deputies arrived to the scene
Pavlik denied grabbing either of the
kids but they got conflicting reports
from multiple eyewitnesses who
identified Pavlik as the suspect
ultimately he was taken into custody and
placed in the back of a squad car while
there's no body camera recording of his
arrest an in-vehicle camera caught
pavlik's range of emotions after he was
taken into custody
God help me I'm innocent until proven
guilty guilty till proven innocent
I am innocent and they are taking me to
jail
for nearly 40 minutes Pavlik can be seen
in the back seat of the squad car
discussing topics ranging from Nazi
Germany to animal abuse just one minute
into the recording public can be heard
praying and discussing hell
sure
they all go help
[Music]
so sorry God I didn't do this
oh
I should have hopped the fence Pavlik
then begins a pattern of maintaining his
innocence while asking to be released
I am an innocent man being falsely
arrested
innocent
it's crazy Jamie Mariah Jamie Mariah I
hope you've helped me God please
sir are you the arresting officer I am
explain to me what I got arrested for
like told you that you it's my fourth
time you listen to lies or the truth
can I please be released
can I see my paperwork
I where's my cell phone
per your request you said give it to
your friend
okay I gotta give them the uh code
launch nuclear weapons Google or
actually use Bluetooth or blue something
right hey blue
actually I'm not going to do that
what is the system called again
Blue Shield
Scientologist
you're a Scientologist
God please help me
delivers me from evil
sir are you really going to take an
innocent man to jail
can I write my own report
sir what is your name I told you three
times I don't remember sir that's a bad
sign
I can't read it I better turn it
sideways
you know I'm innocent correct
after this Pavlik discusses the alleged
incident saying he never left his
property or touched any student
foreign
Ty the telephone pole I was sitting up
behind it just remember that federal
government
get vaccinated and die I hope never mind
I can't say that I'm on record
as I am 100 confident
I am a hundred percent confident I'm
being held against my will no you're
going to jail yeah you are being helpful
I'm going to write a sworn statement
against them okay that's fine you can
what yeah
we're going to jail today
should I resist well you can't resist
you're in the back of a patrol part
already
I'll I'll fight till I die I've done it
before you just go with the flow okay
there's no point of doing that right now
okay you're just gonna can I get some
water please yeah we'll work on that
okay
just don't dig a deeper hole okay let
the court system do the thing the cord
system is corrupt next he makes a
shocking comment about killing everybody
before demanding water hey I'm about to
kill everybody
I'm sorry I can have some water please I
gave you some I need more
here we go
I need it all it's then that public
begins a rant about Jeffrey Epstein that
turns into a discussion about World War
II
do I need to bang my head a few times do
I need to hang myself or are you guys
going to hang me like Jeffrey Epstein we
lost the war to the British
but the checks my grandma and grandpa I
can't even speak of
but let's just say you know
let's just say you know what Blitzkrieg
is can I ask you a question
you know what you know what it was right
okay I'll tell you what it really was
every single German got a German
shepherd and Hitler gave the order to
cut their tongues out or kill yourselves
they built trenches like they thought in
World War One
and guess what they got a bunch of
hungry
you got a German Shepherd Pavlik then
addresses the camera head-on once again
maintaining his innocence
guys I am 100 innocent they are
believing some crackhead drug addicts
because I yelled at him
I was just walking my cat where is my
cat Long Johnson I dropped him off at
Chad's house
what are the Ten Commandments
sir they're bringing me to hell and
you're bringing yourself there as well
as the recording continues Pavlik
suggests jumping out of the squad car
before discussing weapons animal abuse
and Christianity this wasn't supposed to
happen
should I jump out of the vehicle right
now and kill myself trust me I can and
I'll post this minute with my head and
go rolling down the street
I have your AR-15
do you have a Glock 17 or 19.
last time I got arrested I came home and
shook my dog
prove it
did you hear what I just said a
wrestling officer
arresting I don't need a chance
can you see these cups this is the
oldest torture like this is literally I
had hands behind your back Jesus had his
hands behind his back carrying a cross
and he broke his back are you
Lucifers
I saw my soul to God I'll trust in Jesus
Christ you stole your soul to the devil
because you listen to some meth addicts
drug test huh
guaranteed
and y'all are gonna have fun
nearly 30 minutes into the recording
poflick begins lashing out physically
whatever I don't know I don't want to
hurt myself in jail it just hurts more
later Pavlik threatens legal action I
didn't get a Douglas Pryor's number
out
with the brakes
he then inquires about jail making
shocking remarks about his last stint
Behind Bars I'm not a clone right now
it's hot outside
expect me to eat jail food sodium you
can drink less water am I going into
quarantine still
you have no idea what you're doing sir
are you good are you guys going to take
me into jail again and tell me to say
BBC and you'll let me free
remember what y'all did to me I was
screaming bbcp I need BBC
I did anything they told me to
you want BBC big I thought I meant big
black big block Chevy Medical
Center now bro you have no idea
I hope you go to jail for arresting an
innocent person I'm an across the key
always
I'm gonna prosecute your children never
mind I'm so sorry as the recording ends
Pavlik references Satan and the fourth
Reich I'm with Satan right now hey
Google I believe whatever Blue Book at
Liberty Mutual I know you're listening
to me
this is evil this is Nazi America
Aussie America Ozil
don't have to wait now they have
everything this man is a Nazi the fourth
Reich has taken over America public now
faces two counts of battery he was
booked into the Hernando County
Detention Center where he's still being
held on twenty thousand dollars Bond
reporting for long crime Network I'm
Sierra Gillespie